uh very excited to welcome you to the
third annual uh sung seongyang park uh
memorial lecture uh slingham park
graduate school of 1965 and marguerite
clark park memorial lecture we were
really just getting started with the
park lecture a few years ago and then
covet happened so although the lecture
has been around for about five years
this is only the third one um and i will
um i will i will let our chair uh fontsu
kim introduce our speaker but just
briefly i'd like to tell you a little
bit about the lecture itself um the
sunyang park and margaret clark park
lecture
was made possible by a really generous
gift from the estate of the park family
um and so the principal objective is to
foster the study of korea at yale by
bringing recognition to the korean
peninsula and its affairs and
achievements to yale and the wider
community um and you know i'd like to
just briefly say that professor dr park
was
a really generous and insightful alumni
uh along for for yale um he graduated
from the
um from here under phd here in 1965 in
economics um and then he went on to
teach at the
um university of california berkeley
school before um
expanding you know his father's company
to one of the top conglomerates in korea
um but importantly for yale um he really
had a very um
you know a really active role in
promoting yale in korea right and as we
work now to build our korea program um
that's really an honor to be able to
continue that legacy um so among the
other things that he did at yale he was
a member of the president's council
council international activities he was
on the board of advisors for the yale
economic growth center and served for
many years as the president of the yale
club for korea and so in many ways he
was really
yale's biggest champion
in korea and we're really i'm so glad to
be able to continue that um that legacy
but um with that i'll turn things over
to uh professor huan tsukim uh professor
of religious studies to introduce our
speaker today
thank you so much for coming on a very
chilly day
so it's my tremendous honor and pleasure
to be able to introduce my senior
colleague professor qin park
dr park is currently professor and the
chair of the department of philosophy
and religion at american university
she received her ba and m.a from yonsei
university in seoul south korea and her
phd from the state university of new
york at stony brook in 1998.
professor park is not only
a prominent scholar of korean buddhist
studies but also leading scholar of
korean studies
in the west
it's true that professor robert boswell
has been
the towering figure of korean buddhism
but he's retiring this semester
so while professor park is nowhere near
retirement herself
and while she might not might disagree
with me on this
but i would say that very soon she will
become the most senior scholar
of our field
likewise in terms of korean studies
broadly she is now one of the most
accomplished female scholars
in the field as well so for me
personally
for the past 15 years professor park has
been
a close intellectual intellectual
colleague and mentor deeply influencing
guiding my research in many ways
her interdisciplinary and versatile
research explores
korean and east asian buddhism
intellectual intercultural philosophy
modern korean philosophy and
intercultural ethics focusing on the
intersections of gender violence
politics of
discrimination and marginalization and
negative identity
she is a very prolific writer um
having published three books
um
six edited and co-edited volumes and
more than 60
articles and book chapters so far
so in the first book uh titled buddhism
and post-modernism zen
huayn and possibility of buddhist
postmodern ethics published in 2008
professor park dispels century-old
suspicions of buddhism
as a religion of nothingness
or one that disregards philosophers
and she offers the ethics of tension
as a potential ethical paradigm drawn
from
zen and hawaiian buddhism and postmodern
philosophy with a special focus on
jackie deridar's
deconstruction
the next book
titled reflections of a zen buddhist nun
published in 2014
is a meticulous translation
of a bestseller book published in korean
in 1960
by kim midiop
a writer first generation korean
feminist buddhist nun and philosopher
you can see on the screen
who presents a creative interpretation
of buddhist philosophy and practice
the third one women and buddhist
philosophy engaging zen master kimiyab
is a sequel to reflections of a zen
buddhist nun but a broader in-depth
analysis of kim medium's overall
professor park proposes a new mode of
philosophizing
based on the discussion of king medium's
life experience and world view
she terms this new mode of
philosophizing as negative philosophy
which engages itself with a negative
discourse of our daily experiences
instead of relying heavily on
theorization and abstraction
so i'm sure professor park will
elaborate more on this in today's talk
as i said professor park is also editor
and co-editor of five volumes
approaches to chan sun
zen studies in 2022 makers of modern
korean buddhism 2010
mainly ponti and buddhism
uh 2010 and also buddhism and
deconstruction 2006
comparative political theory and
cross-cultural philosophy
um
in
2009. and in fact she and i have
recently finished another comedic volume
called
new perspectives in modern korean
buddhism institution gender and secular
society which will come out by suny this
december
process park is a recipient of many
numerous grants and has taught as a
visiting professor in korea japan
canada and germany
she's equally active in professional
leadership and service
she currently serves as the vice
president of the american academy of
religion in fact she's the first east
asianist
um to be elected to the position in the
academy's 100 year history
uh she's also uh the president of the
north american korean philosophy
association and also the president of
the society for asian and comparative
philosophy
so it's so great to have you over here
without further ado please join me in
welcoming professor shin park
thank you
[Applause]
okay can you hear me
good thank you very much for the
generous introduction and thank you for
having me here i'm really happy to be
here and
sharing my research with the yale
community
so after the pandemic even though we are
still wearing masks just in person event
is
both exciting and a little bit worrisome
right so
um i know so in the department we just
did a the first in person
event since pandemic couple of weeks ago
it's exciting but at the same time
something is different so but anyway i'm
really glad to be here in prison not on
june
and i'd like to share with you about my
research on women and then women and
buddhism so as professor kim mentioned
this is a research that i did for a long
time and a little bit of the genesis of
this research
so after i finished my dictation on
buddhism and post modernism
my focus at that time in buddhism was
pre-modern i was working on
13th century korean genre sun master
chino so after i finished my education i
began to think about
modern korean buddhism what happened in
buddhism in modern times because after
all i compared
13th century
sun buddhism with the 20th century
french philosophy
so what happened to it is nowadays so i
began my research on modern korean
buddhism and believe it or not about 20
years ago the modern korean buddhism was
not studied even in korea it was a very
rare occasion it changed it rapidly for
the past 20 years but anyway as i
started working on modern korean
buddhism naturally a question arose
what happened to women where are they
the possible available materials are all
about buddhist monks right or men
obviously as usual and i couldn't find
the materials on
korean
nuns
in terms of number actually there are a
little bit more korean buddhist nuns
than monks in korea
but then
we don't have materials
so after kind of struggling to find the
materials i
came across a book
which is not an academic book but a book
written by a journalist
he now got his ph.d and he became an
academic but he was a reporter in the
buddhist newspaper and he was interested
in for whatever reason interested in
buddhist
buddhism
so he kind of began to run a series on a
newspaper uh
introducing korean buddhist non in
modern period starting from the very
beginning which was in 1910 1920.
so each chapter in the book has about 10
pages 15 pages about the life and then
when when the person became a british
nun what the person did and died right
and when i got to give me the section
that's only 15 pages i read it and said
wow this figure is interesting
there might be something but because
it's only 15 pages i couldn't kind of
tell much about it so they'll begin the
journey or they'll begin the journey so
i began to look up the materials
i've been to all the kind of second-hand
book bookstores and then library book
copies and so on and so forth
and it was an interesting kind of
journey so as i just told you that i
encountered i discovered the game meetup
as a buddhist scholar
but once i began to talk about gimmedia
my parents generation they own no give
it up not because they are buddhist
scholar because kimito was a celebrity
in her time right so that really gave me
also another thought if she was that
much influential for my parents
generation how come i don't know her
even though i'm a buddhist scholar so a
lot of questions that kind of came to my
mind and
over the almost two decades and my
questions about community arguments
works and changes and edited so there
are kind of a lot of different kind of
questions and issues i explored with
gimme dab and that was also because
gimme up's life itself is panoramic
there are different dimensions in on
life and each stage kind of gave us a
new kind of questions
so in this presentation i will give you
kind of a uh
i will tell you about gamif's life from
the beginning almost the end right
that story i'd like to give you within
the big frame so these are two questions
i want to kind of ask
uh in this presentation first one has to
do with women and buddhism
so how and why do women engage with
buddhism
so i mean each individual has different
reason to
learn buddhism or practice buddhism and
so on and so forth
now my question here is is that whether
women has a specific reasons
or journey which is different
from their male counterpart
that's one question which is related to
obviously gender issue and the women's
issue and buddhism and gender issue
and i'd like to expand the scope a
little bit more and the second question
then women in modern korean intellectual
history as you will see shortly
definitely camilla was one of the main
figures from my perspective in modern
korean intellectual history
but where is she
in the history of modern intellectual
kind of history
so
the second question would be women in
modern korean intellectual history how
and where do they meet
so
i'd like to address these questions by
going through kimberly up's life and
thought camilla was born 1896 and died
1971
and obviously korean buddhist
non-thinker so there are different kind
of phases in gamerop's life which kind
of shows us different intellectual
aspects of gimida so the first one is
her christian background
kimidok's father was a christian pastor
and look at the date she was born 1896.
so her father was the first generation
korean protestant pastor right
and
obviously he was a very faithful kim
media described her father in one of her
essays that
he is most faithful christian in the
entire career
right and
her mother obviously was also very
faithful christian
growing up in this kind of a christian
family chemida
herself was obviously very faithful
christian and she envisioned her future
as a christian missionary
when she was only seven or eight years
old she said that she's going to go to a
place where there the people do not know
about god she's going to send god's
message
well that was good but then eventually
during her teenage years she began to
have a doubt about christianity
and i think these doubts she had
were kind of doubts any christian could
have had so the questions like if god
created a world why are there so many
bad things in the world and so on and so
forth
these are the questions that theologians
discussed for centuries
but when comedian tried to ask this
question to her father
who was a very conservative
evangelist
he stopped her and told her you think
about that kind of thing because your
faith is not strong enough
pray that is the only answer
so this kind of attitude of her father
backfired
so because she could not get an answer
to her questions eventually she lost her
faith in christianity around she was
late in eight years
then after that until she encountered
buddhism then for ten years she didn't
have a religion
another kind of important aspects of
gamirev's life is her
education
so
kim it up received education all the way
up to what we now there is called
college
iwa which opened in 1886 was the first
women's
higher education um established by
christian missionary obviously but think
about this the beginning of the 20th
century in confucian korea women were
not supposed to get educated
even when the opportunity opened like
this the first year that iwaka opened
there was no student
and there came one student
who actually eventually became a
translator for royal family
so
in confusion
korea that
educating women is a bad idea right that
because a woman does not need an
education to be a good wife and
and and mother
but
kimiro was one of the this first
generation of korean women who received
the
public education western style education
for women
and committee of credits this kind of
whole opportunity to get educated to her
parents christianity i think that's true
because our parents kind of
were faithful christian they learned
more about the western culture where
that women's education started earlier
so her mother
told her that even though you are a
daughter i will educate you like any
sons and and her mother was criticized
by
the village people why are you educating
a girl what's good about doing that but
she didn't get education
and after she finished um
iwaku at the iwa tang she also had an
opportunity to study in japan from 1919
to 1920.
as many koreans nowadays come to us to
get an advanced education during the
early 20th century the many koreans went
to japan to receive advanced kind of
education and gimmer went to japan and i
believe it was in japan she really got
this idea about the
women's movement
so
as soon as she came back from japan 1920
she kind of established it with other
kind of her friends
the journal titled shinjuja meaning new
women
she became the editor-in-chief and this
journal is credited as the first woman
published by women for the benefit of
women so that's a big thing so that's
1920
and she was the editor-in-chief which is
a big thing right and
here you clearly see the kind of
influence of japanese or feminist
activists
because if you know japan the japanese
case then in japan early in 1910 1911
there uh there were group of female uh
intellectuals who were very much
actively involved with the women's
movement and schwarzkopf raicho was the
leading figure who created
uh the journal called saito saito
literally means the blue stockings you
know the blue stockings right which kind
of 18th century in europe then meant a
kind of radical
kind of women well at the beginning both
men and women were
blue stalking so literally it means a
kind of women's movement
when she when kimira came back to korea
not only she created general shinjuja
but she also created a forum in which
women get together discuss about women's
issue which the name of which the group
was
now
the chinese and korean korean and
japanese the same kanji has a different
pronunciation so seito in korean
pronunciation is chong top
so kimida definitely used that
expression but interestingly camilla i
don't know whether she was not aware of
this expression blue stockings she or
she didn't like blue stockings so she
changed the second character so meaning
of her forum became a bullet tower
instead of blue stockings but he'll
clearly see that the japanese new
women's uh influence on gimmick
so if you see her life in the 1920s from
1920 to 1928 idiot was a very engaged
writer women's movement activist and a
public intellectual here you see give me
it up at the center uh with the korean
um
writers
when i showed this to my students i
asked who do you think is give me the
and students always say center right
center is giving it up i don't know how
they kind of notice that but the woman
with glasses let's give it up and then
also here kimira was giving a public
lecture in 1962 professor kim kind of
showed me this picture lead me to this
picture so this is something that women
gave a public lecture in korea in 1920s
now
in the
integral the kind of first issue of new
women
this is the kind of what we read so what
is uh what are the what what are their
demands so here you see first economic
independence
obviously right second rationalization
and simplification of family system
because family life is a kind of core of
a woman's life third rejection of a
male-dominated traditional thought well
fourth a call for the stronger awareness
of women's responsibility and duties
the the statement is a little bit
ambiguous so right what are the
responsibilities and duties fifth
campaigns uh campaigns by women's
organization and female students for old
women so that they could get aware of
the
various women's issues including health
and child education so here
it could be a little bit radical but
it's not really radical radical in terms
of demands of women for their freedom
right
well
what kimia became notorious
became criticized by the society and
under notoriously was through her
challenge
about the
body politics of korean society
so kim meetup said that a career
society's control of feminine sexuality
in the name of virginity and chastity is
a visual form of gender discrimination
in korean society and can meet up
demanded sexual freedom freedom to love
and freedom to divorce freedom to get
divorced
so here you begin to see that
how korean society in 1920s within the
confucian tradition would accept this
kind of demand
when i first read this uh demand of
gimidab i thought wow how was she able
to be this much radical in 1920s korea i
mean in even
the end of 20th century early 21st
century in korea this could be a radical
demand
and then i i learned that well this is
not only chemical idea but this was a
kind of general trend in the new women
movement which was based on the swedish
uh thinker ellen k
but i'm not going to go there but anyway
so this was the game of
demand known as the new theory of
chastity xinjiang joran
so why sh but what she said is not that
chastity should we should get rid of
chastity that's not what can be upset
right chastity is obviously a visual
form of gender discrimination in korean
society
but she's not saying that therefore we
should get rid of it
but
she redefined
the meaning of chastity
now what she says is that
chastity should be defined as a maximum
state of love for one's lover
not a moral rule that society imposed on
individual
and i think it makes good sense because
what she claims is that if
if somebody is in love with someone else
naturally the person will maintain
chastity be faithful to the person even
when society doesn't tell the person you
should be faithful
when the love is not strong enough then
there comes a problem so it's not an
issue that society control people by
making a rule
and give me the thought that this kind
of
uh idea is is not only for women but for
men as well so here i'm i'm quoting a
passage from my view on chastity article
called
we new woman and new men here you see
that she is addressing both men and
women who want to do away with all the
conventions traditions concepts and who
are determined to bring attention to a
new and fresh concept of life cannot be
strongly resist among other things the
traditional morality and sex which has
ignored our personalities as well as our
individual characteristics
so here you clearly see already kimura's
desire to really maintain her personal
space
which is free from social constraints
well would the korean society um
allow that that's a really big question
so a key media was part of a
women's movement group known as new
women and new women was not just a
korean phenomenon it's a global
phenomenon you see in the us 1890s in
japan 1910s and korea 1920s and in the
korean context
they usually have several different
types of new women and one of the first
type is a liberalist new women tuhitiki
media belong
so their demand is really has a lot to
do with the sexual freedom okay so a
liberalist new woman they demanded
individual freedom
and the freedom to love and freedom to
get divorced
so there are three major figures in this
context kim it up
and
nahi shak
who was a good friend of gimijob who
worked together with gimidab in women's
issues
who was known as the first female
painter in modern painting in korea she
was a really promising painter so i gave
one the self-portrait in 1928 you
perhaps you notice certain kind of very
full vistik impressionist
i think that the
i don't know she uh she studied in japan
early on from a very wealth family but
eventually she had a problem with her
family and marriage and she died on the
street
and another figure is kim jung-sun who
was also known as the first female poet
in western-style poetry the first female
writer in modern career and an actor and
journalist so these women
all had this the first korean woman to
do this and to do that
but also kim jong-un also died she had a
mental problem later and died on the
street so you see that their ending was
not happy ending if you just look at the
ending itself but that's also um
the issue that we need to reconsider so
what happens here key media is a
challenge to society in terms of sexual
freedom and nahesog and kim myung soon
these new korean new women first
generation of korean feminists
this is
exactly the case of value collides
collision right
two different values collide each other
for the new woman morality that
subjugates women to man and limits a
woman's life to that of a wife and
mother
is immoral
and there is a journal which in which a
new woman says this social morality is
immoral because social morality imposed
women to do only something and then
limits women's freedom
however from the society's point of view
the new women who challenge the
traditional virtue of women and morality
for women assigned by the society is
immoral and they are destructive they
are dangerous
so they are dangerous women they are bad
women so until very recently until the
end of 20th century these liberals knew
women they were called by all bad names
some people even called a high suicide
call girl right because they talk about
sexuality in
public space
and people even nowadays said that their
lives are failure
they failed
why
because
nayasak's life was a failure because she
divorced and died alone on the street
kim jong-un's life was a failure since
she
failed with her love affairs and died in
a mental hospital
and kimira's life was a failure since
she failed in a marriage and love
affairs and joined the monastery and
when i read this especially always i
found this is really strange right so
joining the monastery is like
the dying on the street
so in other words
the lives and even the deaths of the new
woman were judged by the patriarchal
ideology not only their lives but even
their death
here i really want to ask
what does it mean when we say that
somebody's lives are failure
what are the standard measurement for
that who make the standards who make the
judgment
can someone's life be judged
by just looking at the end or one aspect
of it we all know that our lives are
messy there are all kind of elements in
there right
so i think this is a very important kind
of issues we need to think about which
also apply to our society right now
right
the evaluation of the new women's lives
and thus by their society evidence that
values of one's life and one's identity
were strictly controlled by mainstream
discourse the mainstream discourse the
korean society says that women's lives
should be like this you should get
married you should be a wife you should
be a mother and die
is that success
if not you are a problem right
individual individually and social
society do not have much room to
creatively engage with their lives
there are different lives that are
possible right
so kimita became keenly aware of the
problems of leading a life in such a
condition
so during the 1920s it looks like gimmed
up was thinking that i can change
society that's what women activists did
right i can change society i can change
social norms and then i can free myself
from this patriarchal society and
eventually she seems to realize that
that's not exactly the end that wouldn't
be sufficient
there must be something deeper than
social constraints and that's the moment
to give me the turns from social
activists to
religious practitioner
so around
1928 kim media began to practice the
buddhist meditation
as i told you before gamer was a
christian she never knew anything about
buddhism she never practiced meditation
but then suddenly she kind of gradually
moved to there
in 1933 she joined the monastery became
a buddhist nun
when she joined the monastery obviously
korean society wouldn't
wouldn't trust her said well she escaped
to monastery she will come back soon
no she didn't right she didn't and that
she was a major figure in korean
buddhist nuns community until her death
in 1971.
so some people says that say that the
committee of john doe monastery because
she failed in our love affairs
and i said well if failing in love
affairs means that you have to go to
monastery almost everybody should join
the monastery right
how many people doesn't have that kind
of experience
so
looking at with this short kind of a
presentation about giving up's life you
could see that
there seems
to be two distinctive phase in gimme
life
and scholars have been claiming that
in other words there is a rupture in
giving up's life
and the rupture happens
her
tongue sure joining the monastery so
before she joined the monastery she was
a feminist activist public figure who
demanded sexual freedom
and after she joined the monastery she
was a sanjan master who led the frugal
life of monastics i mean monastery in
korea it should be yeah should be poor i
mean basically monastics are backwards
traditionally and 1930s 40s 50s
korean monastery was it looks like a
really really kind of a poor at that
time right and the community of led that
life
but from the very beginning i claimed
that two phases of gimmick's life he
made up as a feminist activist he meet
up as a sun master
they are
they are not totally too different
separate kind of aspects of gamerop's
life
these shows these two aspects
of gimmel's life has a kind of one
thread continuing theme which
is
search for freedom
she wanted to be free from the
patriarchal society and that she wanted
to be free from even that there's
something the existential kind of
binding as human beings
and by finding freedom she wants to be
an authentic human being
and that's my claim right
and
so in looking at kimi of the buddhism
now
the first question one can ask is the
relationship between buddhism and
feminism in korean in american voice
scholarship as well that this issue of
relationship between
women and buddhism or buddhism and
feminism have been kind of a hot topic
for a while and some people claim that
buddhism and feminism
are not compatible
why
because in buddhism nothing has
permanent essence
everything exists through causes and
conditions
therefore buddhist concept of self is no
self in other words there is no
permanent independent self in an
individual
what we call self is combination of all
these causes and conditions therefore it
is called no self
on the other hand this claim uh
claims
well women in a patriarchal society do
not have identity
when buddhism claim no self
that doesn't help because women need to
find the self to lose it
against this kind of a claim kimida
definitely demonstrates
buddhism can help women to liberate
themselves
and that's one of the way of reading kim
it's
buddhism
so how
one of the way gimmed up kind of used
buddhism buddhist concept of self for
her family's agenda is to reinterpret
the concept of buddhist no self
kimira uh introduced two types of self
one is called the small self sora the
other is called grey self or big self
tear
in other words the kind of everyday self
which is gendered and which confines
individuals within their boundaries is a
fragmented self
it up calls the self small self
the kind of gender itself
woman that is small self as well
on the other hand based on buddhist idea
idiot claims that
once one realizes a provisional nature
of this limited vision of the self
one finds the buddhist no self a self
that has capacity to creatively engage
with the life
right that is what is called great self
so here the the great i is i who realize
that women's namelessness and
patriarchal society is not their real
self
one has enormous capacity to create
one's identity which is much bigger than
any kind of confinement
that is imposed by human body or
physical environment or social norms
right
so the great eye is a vision of the
individual who has a capacity to
challenge the mainstream discourse
which imposes a fixed identity to
individuals based on the categories an
individual might have to belong to based
on one's society right so for 4k media
the patriarchal korean society is
imposing of
the gender identity woman
is a small self right but kimiro thought
that everybody it's not only just women
everybody has a capacity to create
people engaged with life in their own
way
if we
translate interpret this the uh
claim of giving up in 1960s to our 21st
century american or society then we can
say that great i is the is the i that
can challenge the discriminatory
treatment of one's identity be it
related to gender race sexual
orientation or social class right
so great i
has to do with the power and strength to
define one's own self freely
and in doing that definitely one needed
to challenge status quo
because status quo does not always kind
of give you the life and definition of
the self you think that who you are
so you know i think this is a very
strong kind of argument kimida is making
after
her kind of years of buddhist practice
and she defines the characteristics of
the great self as creativity and i think
it makes a lot of sense because if you
want to
engage with your identity and your life
away from the kind of a fixed identity
imposed by the society you need a
creative engagement with life
and the exercise of creativity is
vision of buddhist practice and also her
advice to women who search for freedom
and authentic self
here
here i kind of mixed two very important
aspects of gimme of buddhism the first
one is that exercise of creativity is
giving up the vision of buddhist
practice and
not many buddhist practitioners with
scholars or buddhist teachers
use this expression creativity as a kind
of
way of practicing buddhism
and one of the interesting part of kim
it up the um
buddhism is that her interpretation of
buddhism is very unique in her use of
language
expressions like this
i don't know where it came from partly i
think it also has to do with her
background in christianity but
i'm yet to find all the kind of
influence or simply her genius right the
also her advice to women's issues so she
she is advising women if you want to
have a freedom from gender the
patriarchal society you first need to be
able to find your own self right the
creativity and kimira even
interpret the buddha in this way so i'm
quoting the buddha is a being who fully
exercised the creativity
with which each being was endowed
a creator is not a special being even an
insect can be a creator if it recovers
its original mind
so this is a kind of a full declaration
about the individual's
capacity to form
his or their own life without being
constrained by external forces
and she also used this expression
culture
when creativity
creative activity really get together
and appear in a more physical form it
becomes culture
so
she said there's a quote
i was aware that to be a person of
culture meant to be a direct disciple of
the buddha who is the great person of
culture and that was why i joined the
monastery and this is another very
community
like
expression the buddha is the great
person of culture you know which means
forgive me buddha is the one who 100
percent exercise his creativity freedom
now here give it up
kind of
goes back to christianity i told you
that give me the um
gave a christianity late teenage years
and she didn't talk about christianity
for the case until late 1950s
[Music]
at that time she was already in her 60s
and partly i think that has to do with
her relationship with
her father
her father was a faith faithful
christian christianity is her father's
life
and kim meedup had
unusually close relationship with her
father
of you might know that in confucian
society father figure is a very kind of
a distant chemical and giving up his
father they were very close
and
it looks like a forgive me of
criticizing christianity
would be something similar to
criticizing her father's entire life
right perhaps because of that and other
reasons she didn't talk about
christianity for a long time and by the
end of 1950s perhaps she now felt
confident she talked about god and
redefine christianity and god from
buddhist perspective and she says
god is not a creator of the world but a
being that fully exercises creativity
and she said if you if you say that god
is the creator of the world then you are
kind of insulting god because in the
case god is responsible for all the bad
things in the world
obviously theologian says all kind of
explanation about this but that's a
giveaway of the kind of approach
and she put god in the buddha in a kind
of same kind of category and saying that
the buddha and god originate from the
same seed
so god is not the object of one's
worship but rather a model or evidence
that a being is in its ultimate sense of
wholesome and not fragmented
at the end of her life as a last book
which was published in 1964 and give it
up died in 1971
she kind of focusing on this expression
life force is hanging
at the final stage of her life idiot
focuses her philosophy on life or life
force
life is what is shared by all the beings
human non-human even inanimate beings
and that is a foundation of existence
to be aware of one's existence through
its foundation the life force is one's
way to get engaged with one's
existential ecology by focusing on the
life which is a really bottom foundation
of existence idiot was claiming the
equality of all beings
and in this case all beings include not
only humans and non-human animals
non-human emilia animals and inanimate
beings
right
she's talk about even a kind of piece of
broadcast has freedom
so this is a kind of
it's a symbolic statement but it really
tells us how confidence about the
equality of all existing beings
so
because she was such a kind of a
prominent figure in women's movement
before she joined the monastery one of
the questions constantly raised about
give me the ups and life and thought is
this question
what happened to women's movement to
turkey media after she joined the
monastery
in fact she never explicitly talked
about women's movement after she joined
the monastery
even though i read give me of buddhism
in a very much a kind of feminist
perspective
now
there is another way of approaching this
issue
i mean
the women's women's movements can be uh
can be done in various different ways
right the findings are done in various
different ways some people go on the
street and protest some people can write
a book some people can do something else
to promote certain agenda and i think
the gimmick's passwords in a different
way so here is one way of explaining
gimmed up's position about women's
movement
when kimi have joined the monastery in
1928
no 1933
her master janmaster mangong who was
very well-known sun master at the time
told her
i know you are very well known writer
and speaker in the secular world outside
if you join the monastery you don't read
you don't write can you do it
i mean if you're a writer you understand
how difficult it is for a writer not
writing right
gimme up said yes
and then she didn't
publish at least until
late 1950s so about she maintained she
kept this promise for about two decades
i was asked when i had an interview with
the gamer of the disciple vol song
singing did she really didn't write
anything and then
where song
sunim told me that it looks like she
wrote something
but she never showed the her writings to
anybody she didn't publish right so
so anyway she kept her promise there
now
starting from late 1950s she began to
publish again
and the book that i
uh translated
in korean reflections of the jan
brisunon was published in 1960 and then
another book having burned away my youth
the chances
was published in 1962 and then the last
book the book of renegade psl in in
between happiness and misfortune
was published in 1964.
now if you read this book these books
you
kind of
at first you get confused when i first
read her book i was confused i'm reading
a buddhist nuns book
and what you read there is her love
affairs
obviously that happened before she
joined the monastery right but she
talked about her love affairs her
friends love affairs and so on and so
forth
what is going on here right
where is buddhist philosophy right
now if you really begin to
rethink about the situation and trying
to digest
what was give me your trying to do here
then you can
get some different kind of inspiration
in the book committee of kind of talk a
lot about the life stories of various
people
including her own right lives and deaths
of her family members her love affairs
her friends love affairs
and the practice of christianity and
buddhism so in a way it is biographical
writing
autobiographical writing biographical
writing for her friends
but once you begin to
read and think about the meaning of it
and then in between she kind of talked
about buddhist philosophy buddhist
doctrines
at the beginning of this the 1960
publication reflections of january 9 she
says that in the in the preface
well nowadays people do not want to
think about the serious things
if we're trying to talk about religion
they don't want to
read it
so in order to kind of keep them my
reader i
mixed my personal stories with buddhist
doctrine
and i made that she used this bibimbap
right
so that was her
expression but i think there is a lot
there are a lot more than that
so
if you read the things true and then you
begin to realize that the diverse topics
along with idiop's unique way of
delivering buddhist philosophy
uh mark her books as an alternative form
of doing philosophy drawn from women's
lives in the milieu of daily experience
if you are familiar with
philosophy textbook the kind of standard
philosophy book you read in philosophy
course
there's no personal lives
philosophy is supposed to be about ideas
because philosophy should be universal
personal lives personal experience is
particular
that cannot be universal that is a
main assumption especially modern
european modern western philosophy
and if you
apply that
then you see that
there are many kind of aspects of life
they should be excluded in philosophical
discourse right life is not always about
ideas there are a lot of messy things
going on in everyday life
so idiot's writings are a way of
remembering existence in words
by retelling her own life story and
those of her female friends idiot made
women's lives visible
right that is what writing does
your life is written
and then it's there instead of being
forgotten
showing that a woman's life is not a
disposable and forgettable component in
a patriarchal society
her narratives are the witnesses to her
life and the lives of other women
this was it europe's way of engaging
with women's issues
and i think this is important aspects of
promoting women's agenda as much as
explicitly saying that i'm engaged with
women's movement or go out and do
protests there are different ways of
doing a protest right
so here
i kind of a place give me ups life and
thought three different kind of uh
dimensions
first gimbal of life and thought in the
context of women in buddhism which it
was a title of my talk
and then after that you can think about
in the context of intellectual history
of modern korea because definitely give
me up should be there
in the intellectual history of korea
which has not been the case
and then
further the in the context of the
position of non-western philosophy and
women's philosophy
vis-a-vis
male-centered and west-centered
philosophy i mean if you have taken any
philosophy course tell me how many
women's writings have you read
how many non-western
writings have you read
how many non-western women's writings
have you read
here the answer is clear right
so
there are a lot of kind of philosophical
arguments you can make with that but one
thing that you can really think about is
what uh milanda freaker says that
epistemic injustice
when you talk about injustice we talk
about social injustice when you are
mistreated in a
in
society
institution
but here epistemic injustice is the
injustice that happens before that
social injustice a visible form happens
in other words because of your mindset
before you hear something you already
made a judgment about that person right
so when we hear about the sexual
harassment we always emphasize this
right it's not the the victim's at fault
but there's always kind of pre-pre
assumption that who's right who's wrong
so in this book uh milan africa talked
about two different types of epistemic
injustice the first one is homeownerical
injustice the second one is testimonial
injustice a mechanical injustice has to
do with interpretation right so
quoting a gap in collective
interpretative resources puts someone at
an unfair disadvantage when it comes to
making sense of their social experiences
so when new women talk about their their
kind of experience of society and
injustice
the society already made a judgment
that's epistemic injustice right
hermeneutical injustice they are not
going to listen to
them the second one is testimonial
injustice
which occurs quoting when in prejudice
causes a hero to give a deflated level
of credibility to a speaker's word
in other words you hear some women's
experience and okay that makes sense
but that's not as important as
what is said by my male colleague for
example right this is what we always
still kind of experience and then the
new women
phenomenon in korea or
kimi of the life itself really shows us
how this type of epidemic injustice
really
kind of
constrained women's life and many people
who are at the margin
in a patriarchal korean buddhism italy's
position in modern korean buddhism
demonstrates the patriarchal nature of
korean buddhism that continues to refuse
to acknowledge the importance of women's
search for identity and existential
value and the practice continues today
in korea i wrote in english
so i published a book about
kimidow in in english but in korea there
isn't no publication about committee of
buddhism nobody studies it
right even nowadays
they do not think media is important
she's just somebody who talked about
talk about love affairs
so when i
translate that book he made up the first
book reflections of janmaster
that book was supported by korean kind
of a
government project when that book was
elected
in korea people said why do we need to
translate a woman's who talk about love
affairs
the only reason that was that book
survived was
the person who's in charge of the
translation was robert boswell who
uh prophet king mentioned the big figure
in korean buddhism and the robot said we
should do it and korean people just said
yes right otherwise i don't think it
will ever happen
which
shows that still still there there are
there's no kind of a
scholarship on give me a buddhism itself
right
in silencing and silence the voices of
the new women or women have been
silenced in korean society not only in
the 1920s
but for decades until the 1990s when
women scholars began to re rediscover
them so new women's stories
were not discussed in academic setting
until 1990s
in korea in between in korea there was
always excuses
there was colonialism there was korean
war there was a economic development and
so on and so forth
should be more important than women's
issue which is nothing from korean
perspective right that's why that the
women's voice is not there in the
intellectual history of modern korea
right
where do we find the women's voices in
intellectual history of modern korea
so iraf's writings and life reveal one
of the missing parts in this history
and
the third aspects that the the new style
of philosophizing so as professor kim
mentioned before when when she he
introduced me i call gimmed up's
philosophy narrative philosophy
so narrative philosophy is not something
just to kind of discuss ideas
but this is a philosophy which
talk about narrate about one's
experience and from there trying to
construct the meaning of existence
one of the reasons women have been
undervalued in the traditional
philosophy is that because women's life
events have been taken out of the
context of their lives and become
objects of judgment based on the
standards established from patriarchal
perspective
therefore the women's stories are always
about how to hold life and then
that's nothing this kind of attitude
really push women outside of dominant
philosophy
the non-western philosophy and religion
in the western academia has been treated
as inferior because they do not fit in
the standard and the style of western
philosophy
but why should western philosophy be the
standard for philosophizing right
and each of the books show us how
narrative of women's lives help us
understand women's lives and different
forms of meaning production based on the
life stories
so in a way just to kind of as a as a
conclusion
our research on committee awakens us to
the double or triple discrimination in
our society and scholarship right
in the context of korean studies the
complete disregard of kimberly's
buddhism in korean buddhist community
and buddhist scholarship demonstrates
the patriarchal nature of buddhism
practicing korea as well as in the
korean buddhist scholarship and academic
community
in the context of intellectual history
of modern korea silencing of a woman's
voices reveal the incapacity of korean
society and scholarship to deal with the
diversity of human endeavor to
creatively find meaning in existence and
community so i think the the kind of
silence and the tradition of silencing
different voices throughout 20th century
obviously kind of
uh
let korean society the capacity to deal
with these different voices now in 21st
century and society became more and more
rigid
on the other hand adaptive buddhism
offers us a way for women to engage with
buddhism in their search for freedom and
identity so buddhism can be can be
thought of within the context of a
woman's search for freedom it helps
narrative philosophy and buddhism that
is based on the experience of women's
daily life
offers an alternative to the dominant
philosophy and thought tradition in the
academia that exclusively validates
west-centered and male-dominated
philosophizing thank you
thank you
thank you so much this is a really
interesting up i would really love to
hear more about her concept of the great
eye
just how does she sort of explain this
concept is it something similar to like
buddha nature is she engaging like a um
kind of absolute versus conventional
truth binary like yeah what is the great
eye that that she explains
that's a very good question right so so
you use this kind of a buddhist
vocabulary right uh conventional and
ultimate or the buddha nature i think
that
so what kimita was
thinking but interesting another
interesting part of gamila's buddhism is
that she rarely use this buddhist
vocabulary she uses it in her own way
so great i
i use
explain the great eye here a little bit
more um socially engaged concept
she put it in a very abstract way
sometimes which is a great eye is the um
the eye of nothingness
so that is part of it right so in a way
it has to do with emptiness
total openness of
being
so
one of the expressions she used is the
the root of nothingness mucha puri the
root of nothingness that is a foundation
of existence and that is great i
which is
i before the
the third of i arises
it makes sense i
opponents i
before the third of i already in the
second eye that you have a kind of
boundary arises
and she uses this expression a lot a
thought before a thought arises
so it is the first thought is this kind
of total openness of our
pool of thought thinking whereas
thought before a thought arises when
thought arises already this thought was
compromised we already see things from
kind of our own perspective when i look
at the water bottle i already see it as
i can drink water right instead of i
don't know what
water bottle want to be except being
drink by me but that kind of idea right
total openness
so yeah
so that's true it could be buddha nature
and in an ultimate sense right at the
ultimate level so conventional level
perhaps is limited at the ultimate level
but she rarely uses that buddhistic
the expressions buddhist vocabularies
thank you so much for speaking with us i
just wanted to ask um
did you talk more about what were the
influences in the 1950s that met
start writing again and trying to share
her thoughts
that's a good question
so my interpretation is that by 1950s
i think idia
became confident about herself
so when she joined the monastery so she
joined the monastery in 1933
uh that year she had an interview with
um
the journal called the opening of the
word caviar and there
she said something like
i became i practice buddhism so then i
can be a better writer
like the buddha
so she thought that while writing
doing the writing before you really
fully become a human being that's
nothing you should not do it so i'm
practicing buddhism so then i can be a
great writer like the buddha himself so
she invested this time about 20 years
more than 20 years
to really think about what it means to
exist
what is freedom and so on and so forth
so by mid-1950s
she must have felt confident now i can
do the writing without kind of a being
tempted by
fame and so on and so forth i mean if
you're a writer partly there's also that
kind of aspect right i want to be famous
i want to be celebrity
and so on and so forth so i think that
by the time she's in her 60s and she
became confident about herself and she
also talked about christianity right
yeah so
that's my interpretation there's no as
far as i know i read almost everything
give me approach that that are available
right
and there is no indication that there
was any
instant
that made her kind of publish or works
so
if there's nothing like that then it's a
kind of gradual training she trained
herself for 20 years and then by the
time she perhaps thought that well now i
can do it again go back right
was also really interested in the the
small eye of great eyes
concepts and building on the last
question about that it seems to me like
the the so the small eye is the self
that's still strained by is some you
know conventional truths and the day of
the great eye is more
i think it's still a conventional self
because it ultimately is known itself
but it's sort of overcome that you reach
that enlightenment beyond the convention
and i think that
is very helpful in thinking about these
buddhist terms about like what it is to
get beyond that conventional truth and
this was kind of coming up here you're
talking instance of by overcoming
the constraints of concepts like gender
and that's on the cell i can see that
happening on an individual level
realizing okay i'm not constrained by
these things but what about on the
larger social level
and this is the same problem we run into
with critical theory we can talk about
critical theory but if we don't get
those who are out there in society in in
positions of power positions to
influence spreading information to see
beyond
the conventional truth that of concepts
how does the violence stop getting done
is there anything implicit or explicit
in her writing that points to that or is
this strictly a self-enlightenment
cultivation thing
so
i can answer that in two different ways
first one no she doesn't talk about
social issues that much after she joined
the monastery right so
her great eye is very much individual
level of enlightenment issue right but
then she also offer it to any woman who
wants to be free any individual
should who want to
lead a critical life should really
trying to exercise this a great eye
right so
on the one hand that is an invitation to
self-cultivation so that that person can
be a
[Music]
valuables the valuable member of a
society and actually after in one of the
book panel about this game of the book
uh leah cumminson who does japanese and
buddhism actually she wrote a wrote a
kind of article about the committee of
and and feminism and there she said that
well meditation is not an individual
event right because
by doing meditation you want to be a
better person you want to achieve
certain type of
state which cannot be just limited by
yourself right especially in buddhism
when everything is connected if one
person
reached a certain state
that person's capacity will illuminate
and have an influence on others
therefore meditation is a political
action that's why she said and in a way
that is a good way of seeing
uh the influence of religion or the
self-cultivation even though in our
society that type of individual
influence is not that much value that we
always want to see something right and
grasp it so tangible visual way but i
think that's an important aspect
on the other hand it's true kimito has
been criticized for lack of that clear
social vision right like jan buddhism
has been right then buddhism has been
criticized because of that and the gay
media was criticized for that too in a
way i'm defending in europe to bring
this
meditation and
social political action and so on and so
forth i think both are true from my
perspective
so
my parent generation my aunt they said
that after coming up the first book was
published
many young korean women joined the
monastery
so you know that that shows the kind of
influence of
uh this uh women and um
well actually after i published the
translation of gimme up's book
the korean community in washington dc
where i live they gave me a small book
party um that's everybody knows
everybody party so about 20 people
joined to celebrate the publication or
give me a book but
that event was kind of announced on
korean newspaper it's not a kind of
invitation but anybody can come back
anyway and then at the at the party one
old lady and young woman came
nobody knew who they were so we were
asking who's that who's that who's that
right so
after kind of a while later we asked the
lady so how did you get how did you get
to know this event and she said dora
says that my mother saw the announcement
on the newspaper and she told me we
should go there
and then she said my mother doesn't read
english
but
she said the mother said that camilla
was the woman in my generation who led a
life which we couldn't do but we wanted
to live right kimira was the one who
lived a life of freedom searching for
her own identity right even though she
was not able to live like that but she
really admired her therefore she wanted
to come to book party right so that for
me that was really really there was a
real inspiration i mean that shows the
kind of influence of giving up on
certain generation of korean women but
it was not only women but my parent
generation male admirer gamer as a kind
of cool girl right
yeah
thank you so much
there's a lot to think about
from your comments and uh
i'd like to ask a question from the
perspective of language um
being a writer
language issues linguistics more broadly
leading into
concepts and notions from a
philosophical perspective
understanding that you know her work so
well
i think
you're in a position to be able to
assess or intuit to what degree it hurt
her language itself changed
over that 20-year
hiatus she wrote before and then she
wrote afterward
and then she wrote afterward from a
state of having realized something
and we all know that language itself
poses these same problems that we
encounter in the broader philosophical
sense
what pronouns you choose we grapple with
this today
in english every language family is
different right yeah but there are
identifiers for language spoken by women
and
language spoken by men across societies
did she
did
i'm just curious whether you've sensed
any difference in her writing um in in
in the way that she
spoke of herself to begin with
and
otherwise grammatical issues uh just
choices of uh what
pronoun to use perhaps
i'm more familiar with japanese but you
can make choices about how you refer to
yourself right uh in a more new neutral
way or as a really very feminine way of
pronouncing something and so on right
yeah that's a great question now i think
about that issue
so before she joined the monastery
she wrote mostly uh poetry or short
stories and couple of short polemics
about the women's issue
and there it's more like a argumentative
tone right and climbing women's issue or
um
she faced a lot of death in the family
she lost all the immediate family before
she reached 20. okay so she talked a lot
about this agony about the
losing family members she wrote in
poetry she wrote in a short story so
that was before um she joined the
monastery so in the later books
i have to say there is some things
a little bit of urgency in the later
book when she talked about the
buddhism so
actually this semester i i in my seminar
we read the gimmick of the book
and then
some student says that she's pushing us
right
she's pushing us and then philosophy
shouldn't be that way and i was thinking
what does that mean that she's pushing
us and you know that's what i think that
urgency in that book right i mean you
shouldn't do this but why are you not
doing it and that is a kind of
the her sense of urgency and then
that's distinctive in the later writing
and she uses a lot of her own way of
expressing things
and sometimes even even in korean
sometimes it doesn't make sense
right i mean i don't know whether it was
a kind of printing uh
the
quality at the time but there is some
passages in the book that i translated
that
they didn't make sense in in korean and
when you translate it you have to
translate it right and i i couldn't make
sense of it from korean trans korean
original so i translated literally
and my copy editor of the publisher
university of hawaii emailed me jin this
does not make sense in english and i
said it does not make sense in korean
either
i'm supposed to do but in a way there is
a kind of mixture of her creativity
right and then like her use of
expression her own expression to
interpret
buddhism so that this urgency and the
creative use of
her uh expressions in interpreting
buddhism i think that
must really um be a distinctive for me
at least that's a good question i would
think about more yeah
oh yeah thank you thanks for really a
wonderful thought i'm afraid i'm very
ignorant about this subject so my
question is a bit uh maybe basic but i
was just wondering um to what extent
you mentioned at the beginning that
they're actually more female nuns
than monks in korea
and i just stand out in contrast to your
comment about you know kind of the
stereotypical view of cambodia being
that she went to a monastery and that
was like the failure of her life right
so i'm just wondering whether either
kind of alongside him adopts time as a
nun or sort of after that ideas about
being a nun have changed in korea or
whether there are other women who are
you know who've taken the torture and
foreign society and whether that has
um taken on new meanings or or there are
like alternative visions of what
being a nun means and kind of post-war
korean society right that's a very good
question right so as you know that
religion had its own function in our
society and pre-modern society for
example monastery was not only religious
space it was orphanage it was a senior
citizen's home right when you after you
get old if you don't have a family to
take care of you join the monastery if
you're a orphan you you are taken care
of by the
monastery so monastery had various
different
social function as they are but in
modern society monastery gradually began
to lose that function also monastery or
religion
had not only this kind of social
function but it had
a kind of special position in our
society because
religious world which is sacred world is
separate from secular world
therefore they had its own privilege in
primary society modern society kind of
get rid of this
distinction
so monastery or religious organization
need to justify its own kind of
contribution to the society
and for women one of the key benefits
from even buddha's time to join the
monastery with education
and getting away from
this family household in life
but gradually gradually when women kind
of get a opportunity to get educated
monastic the benefit of joining the
monastery kind of diminishes actually
though when i joined when i visited
gimmicks place the one of the gamer's
disciples asked me because i've been
kind of doing gimme up
research and gaming why didn't you join
the monastery and then she answered her
own question oh nowadays you don't have
to because you can't get educated anyway
so that was a main issue and because of
that korean society after especially
the mid-20th century began to see those
people who joined the monastery as
somebody who failed in a
secular world right if you are good in a
secular world why do you join the
monastery and actually that book that i
translated
uh committee of the disciple
who served the game meetup until her
last day
she was the one who kind of helped game
it up to publish that book has a show to
kind of
essay of her own she says that when she
trying to join the monastery her family
her parents her brothers siblings they
all cried
and she said i pity them because why are
they crying right because i'm going to
monastery to find something bigger
so in a way there is a gap kind of gap
between the societies the perception of
those people joined the monastery and
those people who joining the monastery
and
obviously in both
monks and nuns a number of monastics are
kind of diminishing the overall case
but i think it's
the woman's case still joining the
monastery was to find their own kind of
life outside of this family setting or
household setting
but um
nowadays i don't think that people would
just say that explicitly right you're
doing the monastery because you failed
right but um
that kind of idea was there and roberto
said the same thing about buddhist monks
in his book gen monastic experience
right when he joined the monastery in
1970s
and then people korean people thought
that there are kind of three type of
korean monks who joined the men who
joined the monastery first a failure in
a society second one was um who was not
happy with the western philosophy right
so they think that the asian philosophy
was better what was the third one but
there was a third one so then kind of uh
lazy people
so that was his categorization but in a
way so there's a mixed
kind of um
reaction nowadays i don't think that
people
explicitly say that you failed because
you joined the monastery but there was
that kind of thing but those people
joined the monastery obviously they have
the bigger uh bigger uh
um
goal
well actually a couple of years ago when
i had a conference in taiwan there was a
hawaiian school which i regularly go for
conference there was a young very young
buddhist nun who just joined the
monastery after she finished college
and since my chinese is not good enough
to communicate to communicate she was
interpreting for me and i just asked
this stupid question right so so you
joined the monastery do you like it
and then she was all smiling and said i
love it right and then at that moment i
realized that yeah there are people
who really are searching for something
something which is bigger than we do in
a secular society right and the
monastery is not totally separate
nowadays and they are all to that thing
will be the last one
thank you very much um i was wondering
if you could tell us a bit more about uh
immediate ideas about culture you
mentioned that culture is like the full
expression of creativity but at the same
time
isn't like culture and society imposing
on people's ability to like fully find
their own creativity and express that so
how did she work that out in her writing
right that's a very good that's a very
good question so she challenges this
patriarchal culture
but she used this expression i'm yet to
find where is the source of her use of
this expression culture right this
culture
uh
also the i i believe the east asian
expression
right that is a translation from western
language that that
like many expressions
that came from western society and along
with the modernization
so
kimberly's idea of culture is the full
exercise of creativity and when this
creativity
culminates right at the combination of
creativity you see certain more tangible
results and that is a culture so for
example cultural artifacts right so nice
building old building at yale that's
culture right in which all the spirit of
the human mind is kind of condensed
but that's a good point give me job
didn't see culture as something which it
can also impose
uh pressure from outside
but
there has been some discussion about
this a different way of taking this
expression culture so western
indo-european expression culture
english culture came from french
cultivate right so cultivate
like a cultivating crop so that's why we
say cultivation
whereas east asian
tradition didn't get that one but
moon is writing and but this the second
character chinese character hua
hua in korean then means transformation
and there i think we can find a similar
idea of a cultivation in english in the
european language
and then transformation and i think
that's a part of kimber's idea about
transforming yourself through creative
activity
right
but i think that your question is really
valid in asking that well she resisted
patriarchal culture but she didn't call
that as a culture and i think it also
this requires a little bit history
historical survey of the evolution of
the concept because this expression
culture itself
came to korea i think just at the end of
19th century and by the time i begin of
the use of that expression
what would be the dominant concept of
culture right so but
thank you so much
thank you thank you very much